Traduttore: Alice Grossi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Siete pronti per scatenare
un po' di felicità?
Sì, come on. Musica! (Risata)
(Musica in sottofondo)
Mani! Mani!
Up! Up! Up!
Yeah, come on!
(Risata)
Wow, che energia!
È l'energia degli esseri umani.
Wow! Evviva!
Sono onorato di essere qui
e di far germogliare, nel vostro cuore,
un po' di gioia, un po' di felicità.
Ecco, del resto questo
è anche un po' il mio lavoro
e anche la mia missione,
quella di aiutare le persone nel mondo
a scatenare questa energia vitale
che abbiamo già dentro di noi:
l'energia della felicità.
Pensate che quando ero
a Puttaparthi, nel sud dell'India
dove ho abitato con la mia famiglia
per diversi anni,
proprio lì, in India,
in questo villaggio sperduto,
ho incontrato per serendipità
questa tecnica meravigliosa:
la tecnica che ti permette di ridere
senza aver bisogno di un motivo per farlo.
Straordinario! (Risata)
Mia moglie ride quando mi guarda
in faccia, ad esempio, no?
È un buon motivo per lasciarsi ridere.
Però sono rimasto
felicemente entusiasmato
dalla magia della risata incondizionata,
perché ti permette di ridere
soprattutto quando le cose
non vanno proprio come tu vorresti.
Ecco, è importante ricordarci
che da bambini ridevamo,
in media, 300 - 400 volte al giorno.
Perché?
Ma il perché ce lo ricorda persino
la scienza medica, quella ufficiale.
Quando noi ridiamo, il nostro corpo
secerne queste sostanze incredibili.
Produce quella che è stata definita
la chimica della felicità.
E questo è straordinario.
Pensate che la scienza ha scoperto,
e non troppo recentemente,
che quando noi ci lasciamo ridere
si abbassa il cortisolo,
che è l'ormone dello stress.
Più ridi, meno sei stressato.
Ma soprattutto, abbiamo osservato
che quando noi ci lasciamo ridere
il nostro diaframma
fa un movimento molto importante,
cioè va a spingere
e va a massaggiare i polmoni,
e permette ai polmoni
di buttare fuori anidride carbonica,
per inspirare una maggiore
quantità di ossigeno.
E questo è fondamentale,
perché sappiamo che ridere ti permette
di ossigenare al 100% le tue cellule.
Questo ci permette
di rimanere in salute,
ma direi proprio di scatenare
la nostra energia vitale.
Vedete, oggi io non sono qui
a fare bla bla bla bla,
ma a fare con voi ho ho ha ha.
Perché questo
è il mantra sacro della felicità.
Vi ricordate il suono della risata?
Straordinario, era: ho, ho, ha ha ha.
Quando tu ridi (Risata).
E la gente nel mondo mi dice:
"ma tu non sei un cabarettista,
come possiamo ridere?"
Lo so.
Come si fa a ridere?
Ridendo!
(Risata)
Ok, avete voglia di scatenare
un po' di risata?
[Pubblico: Si]
Yes! E allora un piccolo esercizio:
braccia in avanti,
ora vi chiedo di portare
le vostre braccia verso di voi
e inspireremo, cioè tirate su l'aria
qua dai buchi del naso,va bene?
Vai!
Inspira.
Trattieni, trattieni, trattieni
- e adesso fuori le braccia ridendo!
(Risate)
Fuori tutto, coraggio. Vai!
Inspira...
Trattieni, trattieni, trattieni,
fuori la risata!
(Risata)
Un po' più forte, dài!
Inspira...
Trattieni, trattieni, trattieni.
Non stai morendo, trattieni. Vai!
(Risata)
Vedi? È straordinariamente semplice.
E quando tu ridi,
il tuo corpo fisico sprigiona l'energia
dell'entusiasmo, della felicità.
E quando noi cambiamo come corpo,
cambia anche la nostra attitudine mentale.
Ma signore e signori,
voi che ci ascoltate,
siamo qui in questo mondo meraviglioso
per scatenare gioia.
Questa è la nostra
ultima destinazione: la gioia.
Un altro esercizio:
facciamo così con le mani,
facciamo la cuffia
- non gli auricolari, la cuffia.
Appoggiamola alle orecchie.
Ora vi chiederò di ridere,
e vi ascolterete ridere.
Se non funzionerà,
è perché non state ridendo.
È scientifico, vai!
(Risata)
Bravissimi: ora ancora la cuffia,
alzate l'antenna, così siete
connessi all'Universo.
Vai! (Risata) Hai il wifi!
Fatevi un applauso, bravissimi!
(Applausi)
Wow!
Certo, quando tu ridi cambi.
E quando tu cambi,
il mondo cambia con te.
Vedete, ridere è davvero straordinario,
perché ci riporta sempre
ai momenti più belli dell'esistenza.
E le persone dicono:
ma io sto vivendo un momento
veramente difficile nella mia vita,
sicché non ho alcun motivo per ridere.
Appunto!
Ora stai scoprendo che puoi ridere
lasciandoti semplicemente andare.
Vi propongo un altro esercizio,
vi va di farlo con me?
[Pubblico: Si!]
Vi prego ora di appoggiare
entrambe le mani qui,
al centro del vostro cuore,
cuore spirituale.
Se vi va, socchiudete anche gli occhi.
Ascoltate questa voce
che ora vi guiderà:
alcuni mi definiscono un po' uno sherpa,
uno sherpa dell'anima.
Cerca di percepire il contatto
con il tuo cuore che batte.
E ora ti chiedo di portare
tutto il tuo respiro
esattamente lì,
nel tuo cuore che batte.
Respira, e porta l'attenzione
sul cuore fisico.
Quando inspiri,
percepisci chiaramente
quest'energia vitale
che ti sostiene,
che ti ama, che ti alimenta;
e quando esali, quando espiri,
lascia fuoriuscire ogni problema,
ogni dubbio, ogni paura.
Quando inspiri, percepisci
questa energia meravigliosa,
che ti ama, che ti sostiene;
e quando esali, lascia fuoriuscire
ogni dubbio, ogni angoscia,
ogni rammarico.
Coraggio, ancora una volta.
Inspira questa energia
meravigliosa, trattienila in te;
e ora lascia andare fuori
ogni paura, ogni risentimento.
Cerca di percepire
il livello del tuo corpo,
della tua energia interiore.
Meraviglioso.
Mantieni gli occhi chiusi,
e ora ti chiedo di portare questa energia
a tutti i tuoi cari, ovunque siano.
immagina di poterli abbracciare
con questa energia meravigliosa.
Osservali, ovunque sono.
Avvolgili in questa energia
di gratitudine, di amore.
Ora ti chiedo di immaginare
il volto di tua madre,
e anche quello di tuo padre.
Al di là di ogni cosa
che può essere accaduta tra di voi,
ti invito ad abbracciarli
con questa energia.
E se puoi, perdonali.
Ma soprattutto, ringraziali
per il sacro dono che ti hanno fatto,
di avere questo corpo.
Ora ti prego di estendere
tutta questa energia
a tutti i tuoi amici, ai tuoi conoscenti,
alle persone che sono qui
in questo teatro meraviglioso.
Allarga questa consapevolezza.
Senti l'energia che vibra
in ogni singolo atomo
della tua pelle, del tuo corpo.
Porta tutta quest'energia, questa luce,
a tutto questo mondo,
agli abitanti di questo pianeta Terra.
Sprigiona la tua gioia ora,
senti il tuo amore.
Continua ad alimentare questa gioia.
Percepisci.
Porta questa luce ovunque con te.
E ora sorridi, sorridi, sorridi.
Percepisci l'energia che scaturisce
nel tuo sorriso, dal tuo sorriso.
Delicatamente, ora,
lascia andare le braccia.
E delicatamente, riapri i tuoi occhi.
Senti la tua energia vitale.
Senti come il mondo ti sostiene.
Senti come la tua missione
è quella di contribuire
a generare felicità.
Aiutando gli altri.
Amando te stesso.
Sentila ora questa energia,
che trema in ogni singolo atomo
della tua vita.
Il passato è passato,
Il futuro è incerto.
Ora è il momento più importante!
Lancia ora, nel campo fertile
della tua mente subcosciente,
il seme della consapevolezza
di ciò che tu sei.
Ho ho, ha ha!
Ripetilo con me:
ho ho, ha ha!
Più forte, più energia!
HO HO, HA HA!
Fatemi sentire, con il vostro applauso,
la vostra energia.
Coraggio!
Yeah!
(Applausi)
Ah!
(battito di mani a tempo di musica)
Yeah!
E ora ti chiedo
di farti un forte applauso.
Se farai questo applauso,
significa che porterai
a casa questa energia
e la porterai ai tuoi cari.
Fatemi sentire l'entusiasmo, l'energia!
Yeah!
Certo!
(Applauso)
Yes, grazie.
È assieme che creiamo il cambiamento.
E la cosa che come voi
ho imparato nella mia vita,
grazie a tante sofferenze,
grazie a un fallimento,
grazie a tanti dolori,
grazie al fatto che da oltre 20 anni
mio babbo è nel cielo che mi segue,
grazie a tutti questi maestri
che noi comunemente
chiamiamo problemi, sfortune.
Grazie a questi maestri
ho imparato la cosa più importante:
che ognuno di noi ha la libera scelta
di scegliere la felicità.
Perché anche l'infelicità è una scelta,
e chi compie questa scelta sei tu.
Questo è il seme da far
germogliare nella nostra vita.
Tu sei destinatario di questa gioia.
Quando tu punti il dito verso gli altri,
stai facendo un errore enorme.
Quando tu dai la colpa agli altri,
agli altri amici, ai nemici,
alle istituzioni, alle altre religioni,
alle altre persone
che tu pensi siano sbagliate,
stai facendo un grande errore.
Perché stai veicolando
la tua energia agli altri,
stai dando a loro
la possibilità di decretare
la felicità o l'infelicità nella tua vita.
Quando tu punti il dito verso di te,
sei al centro del tuo cuore.
Quando lo punti verso gli altri ricorda,
come dicono in India,
che "hai tre dita
che puntano contro di te"
Non giudicare.
Vivi la tua vita, non quella degli altri.
Quando tu ridi, cambi.
Ridere non è deridere.
Ridere è l'espressione della gioia,
è l'espressione dell'amore.
Abramo chiamò Isacco,
suo figlio, "Colui che ride".
Ma allora facciamola finita
con la tristezza.
Perché abbiamo ogni fonte,
- ora! ora! ora più che mai! -
per essere persone realmente felici.
Perché, come a voi,
neppure a me mancano otto bicchieri
di acqua potabile al giorno.
Neppure a te manca almeno un pasto.
Neppure a te manca un tetto
sotto al quale dormire sicuro.
A nessuno manca l'ossigeno,
che è la fonte vitale di ogni cosa.
Siamo già fortunati.
E allora rendiamoci conto che
questo mondo è ... (Musica)
Meraviglioso!
Forza!
Ho ho, ha ha!
(Risata)
(Applauso)
La voce!
Cantiamo assieme!
(Applauso)
Thank you, grazie.
Ho ho, ha ha! (Risata)
Grazie!
Wow, che bella energia!
Yes!
Oramai sono in conclusione,
e non voglio tenere troppo
i segreti per me;
anzi, sono venuto qui a gettare anch'io,
come i miei colleghi, gli altri speaker,
dei semi di consapevolezza.
Vi voglio lasciare con questo
- che del resto mi ha lasciato
il mio maestro spirituale in India.
Un giorno feci questa domanda:
"Come posso innalzare
il mio tasso di felicità
dal 51% al 100%?"
Mi è arrivata questa intuizione
che io vi dono,
perché è bello condividere con l'umanità
le cose più belle della vita.
Quando possiamo innalzare
la soglia della nostra felicità?
Mettendo in pratica questo mantra:
Love all, serve all:
ama tutti, servi tutti"
Help ever, hurt never:
aiuta sempre e non ferire mai.
Grazie.
(Applausi)
(Risata)